Này, quý năm trên tất cả bình bư của bập khu trường xang.
Giờ lúc vuyền người, nhà nhà xung bầy đóng tết.
Đó mới trong hạnh đi, các chính xí, bình đang trong vui vẫn vuyền hùng này.
Hãy tổ!
Quà xong, bữa trọng, xong đo phản phá lệ một tụt, kịch thử vực không cầu.
Đây là một trường như thế nhận vụ chính trị trọng tâm của rạ.
Và được hình thật kia thương suyết theo này để quàu kêu hốn nguyện này thì cũng nghe nân cao gên.
Chỉ đỏ thávác sử dụng của cái chăng vệ
Đúng rồi, đã có cách phương ánh
và xây dân cách kế hật cô hả
Bố chỉ lực lượng phương tiền
Trần tăng hướng
và trong tăng nhìn vô cô hả
Để đất liền, ín tâm vô dùng, đón tất
Mạo về chủ quyền của tục cuộc trên biệt đâm
với các chến sĩ, mùa sân ở đây đến theo kích sắp dương
Sa đất liền nhưng chứ tưởng sắc quý hương
Bởi nơi có lắc cơ đỏ sau vàng tục bay
Đã là nơi tổ quốc Việt Nam sấu yêu hiện hướng
Chỉ sĩ trần sang vui
người vừa đến tạm được ít hô
Đấy là tiếp đầu tiên xanh nhạc
Quả nằm tất lắm
em điều cùng chà mẹ ông bà
có bình tế, nằm này là một dịp tất
thật là đặc biệt tại quân đáo trình xa
chứ có mất hình liền của tổ quốc
em cảm thấy rất là vấn rối và tối hảo
khi nắng chưởng quý năm trên biệt đông dành buông
cũng là lúc phân biệt đết của tìm trên các phần lãnh thủ không thể đách sời này
của tục quốc
tết chân đất liền có gì
tết được đào có tương nơi
nếu có khác thì chỉ có thêm lỗi giữa nhà của những chiến sĩ mới
Đây là kết tất là đầu tiên
xa nhà lỗi lúc của một lúc ngã gió nhà nhưng
nhưng hướng hướng sĩ của gắng có ngay đây cũng rất thung nhờ mấy
giới dưới dưới dân chức khuyến
và bà bà chăm mẹ a nhà lúc mẹ
Gó bà ngã mòa
Ờ, một khóc khác nơi đảo xa
giữa nắng sau biệt tạm nàn đến trong những sự phút khối cùng của năm át thì
tương thêm chực vẫn nối tiếp nhau
Đây tổ quốc được biệt đặt có một chương xa
để đách liền như thế
và đách liền luôn nhớ chương xa